hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca I'm falling again today's
Thursday it's that's your recap date we
don't also we really don't have too much
info to talk about as like last week but
there's a few bits of information I'd
like to share with you also as always
like to be if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new and let's get started so
first up if you're experiencing some
server issues no worries you be self was
having issues on all of the games I was
having an issue on my birthday when I
was doing the birthday stream so that
kind of sucks but everyone on the street
definitely noticed that Ubisoft was
having an issue with their servers so as
compensation we're receiving a thousand
steal ten XP tickets and two scavenger
crates which is pretty nice of them next
up realistic Dominion is back in a game
it's basically Dominion with no gear
stands widget the revives and no stats
which is pretty cool if you want to play
that mode you of the entire week to do
so I personally like this mode a lot so
I'm definitely playing that throughout
the week and to pair that up we have a
decent event order that goes well with
this called dominant warrior we're just
to complete the required amount of
Dominion matches for the weekend to
earns 22,000 steal the new content of
the week is gonna be the falling
feathers effect which is about 5,000
steel it's a nice looking if I
personally not my favorite but some
people might enjoy it
and then lastly they had a Q&A to end
the stream I mean there was only one
question being asked and it was
basically what a limited time events be
returning back into foreigner like test
your mettle frost when festival etc and
they said maybe my theory is that
they're going to be adding them back
into the game and either give us all new
gear and that's it and then if you've
got the old ones you kept the old ones
and stuff like that or they're gonna
give us the old gear but also some new
gear to get as well can be had just a
short quick video really not much to
talk about today sorry about that guys
hopefully in the next couple weeks we'll
be getting info on these season 7
research and then maybe some more on
Jang's Union nukes you still hoping that
it'll be the next week after but I keep
getting let down hopefully I won't be
wrong next week though but as always
like the view if you do enjoy subscribe
if you're new I cover the informational
side of for honor my two most rusev it
is we on screen in a psychic because one
check that out and that guys took over
yesterday thank for watching the video
and peace out
[Music]
[Music]
you